[Musique]
et vous êtes allé en tournée oui oui je
reviens de tourner et j'ai fait un
immense périph que réellement pontivy
meung-sur-loire nesles la vallée d'un
martin de ré carpentras lourde
non mais alors je n'ai fait qu'une
apparition en a l'air amaury verdun
alors minée par les hôtels devers eux
c'est le coup de fusil à vous connaissez
oh oui oui j'ai triomphé sans fois vers
non oui dites moi bonjour toujours à la
salle saint-joseph à lennon jours la
salle de l'immaculée conception
c'est bien et qu'ils fassent tous ces
parfaits mais ça n'est pas très gai
n'est ce pas et puis qu'est-ce que vous
jouiez mon récital en récital et syna
sinaoui degorgue qu'est-ce que vous
jouiez d'ancinnes polyclète paix ah je
vois ces esclaves affranchis tizi totaux
deuxième à 12e nouveaux seigneurs
solange l'exécuter c'est extrêmement
délicat jean vient d'autant plus qu'il
ne fait que ce il ne dit que cela
pendant les 5 ans à haïti sans se lever
son verre unix et s'inverse solitaire et
leur avantage en pièces a fait rive
droite
alors si vous l'aviez chauffer le jeu le
très content s'ils veulent ramasser
voilà faut le prendre deux points voilà
toutefois nié que loin du très très loin
du fond du plateau c'est ce que je peux
y aller je vous entends entre mi mai
j'arrivais mais j'arrivais dans un
immense chêne au tragique en temps mon
péplum de la main gauche jusqu'au trou
du play
la première je me suis foulé la cheville
commence à evian en arrivant avec c'est
énorme autorités que je confèrent les
personnages oui j'arrive donc autres du
souffleur et à son la part je tombe de
draft je vous avoue qu'elle accident
bête
oui alors à ce moment là se lèvent de la
salle évidemment un immense cri
d'angoissé tient et pas tarir pas un
sourire non pourquoi ce n'est pas drôle
reste plus sur l'aide simplement souffre
alex que je l'écrasé légèrement enfin je
me dégage et le régisseur fait une
annonce mesdames messieurs le noir est
indemne commerce
messi joue bien nous allons pouvoir
reprendre la représentation alors alors
en revanche élèves de la sarre
bon là un énorme cri de satisfaction aux
et vous avez repris immédiatement du
même endroit à nom d'un peu moins long
c'était je pense alors j'arrive donc
cette fois ci beaucoup plus prudemment
sur va sur la pointe des coaches est
exactement jusqu'au trou du souplet et à
ce moment là paf le trophée elle est
donc c'est une manie on n'arrêtait pas
plonger non le trou de mémoire galaxy
mais le trou noir alors je fais signe à
la souffleuse j'appelle du pied que
croyez vous qu'elle me dit lavera et
bien syndicalement elle doit vous
envoyez votre verre tout quand son grand
seigneur seront et écrite et bien pas du
tout j'en reviens pas du doigt me dit
voilà on n'apprend pas alors on ne s'est
pas calmée ce titre elle petites gens
mais ces minuscules c'est tout petit et
quand vous disiez notre veille
il est car vous disiez de temps à autre
ah oui je n'ai eu un trou que trois fois
l'avait joué souvent six fois c'est bien
vous dise une fois sur deux ans
exactement c'est un orage je pense comme
on le faisait vous je le gueule je peux
vous dire une chose comme ça très dans
le masque très envoyer tout autant le
seigneur avait perdu quelque chose non
c'est un geste une autorité herbe crispé
lui s'éteint à frangy je le fais timbre
est à la fin à ces très graves en a
partout comme distribution des amateurs
jean pierre je vais confier auguste vous
savez dans l'eure où il en fera en bus à
mon excellente ami gaëtan rouge et pyatt
je dois avouer que dans ce rôle il vu
franchement mauvais état ou même si je
les ai vus bien haut dans quoi dans
l'attendu ça c'est son meilleur rôle
emilie qui peut jouer et me dis-je était
une petite starlette ont assez célèbre
l'année dernière et en main ça va si
vite c'est carrière